para analizar entonces qué ocurre
actualmente con el uribismo quiero
saludar al señor león valencia agudelo
él es analista y escritor director
fundador de la fundación paz y
reconciliación leon gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 un gusto de raúl con mucho
gusto estoy complacido estar aquí león
le pregunta entonces qué ocurre
actualmente con el uribismo realmente
llegó el fin de dos décadas de este
movimiento liderado por el ex presidente
álvaro uribe vélez si el presidente
duque que es el dueño del actual
gobierno enterró al uribismo porque ha
hecho un muy mal gobierno y esto sigue
la lógica de las segundas partes en
américa latina nunca les va bien ni a
las segundas partes de la derecha en las
segundas partes de la izquierda por
ejemplo en pues en venezuela maduro
después de chávez
dilma rousseff después de lula en brasil
o ya la derecha
digamos los sectores fujimoristas en el
segundo mandato también
el chile en el segundo mandato
eso es una lógica en américa latina pues
la caída de lori es muy muy fuerte
realmente es estruendosa su líder está
en serios problemas judiciales y hacemos
y el movimiento estaba descuartizado
porque una vez el líder digamos entra en
esta situación tan difícil también al
interior lo que se produce son las
pugnas duras y lo están abandonando todo
todo mundo y es como cuando el barco
está naufragando que en los primeros que
se tiran son los más jodidos las más
ratas como dicen en el dicho pues
estamos en esa situación de la
decadencia del uribismo ese es un
acontecimiento de las actuales
elecciones y eso es lo que ha
posibilitado que emergen alternativas
distintas además porque el malestar
enorme en la sociedad colombiana
a una rabia enorme porque los
acontecimientos últimos de la pandemia
la crisis social porque los
acontecimientos de ascenso de las
izquierdas también han creado un
ambiente distinto por ese estallido
social que hubo en el 2021 y por lo que
está ocurriendo en américa latina
también hay un cambio de tercio en
américa latina están volviendo gobiernos
de izquierda en toda la región y en
colombia que nunca había ocurrido eso
esto es un acontecimiento
impresionante para colombia raúl es que
nosotros llevamos 60 años en una guerra
por la inclusión de las izquierdas las
izquierdas se levantaron en armas para
tratar de que las incluyeran en el juego
político no lo habían logrado pero en
los últimos años han ganado alcaldías
bogotá medellín cali y ahora se aprestan
a ganar las elecciones presidenciales es
un acontecimiento político para la vida
colombiana y creo que hay una novedad
muy grande en américa latina con este
triunfo posible obviamente faltan unos
días para la primera vuelta y luego
faltará la segunda vuelta y la cosa no
va a ser tan fácil
pero tiene muchas posibilidades las
izquierdas de llegar al poder ahora le
van yo le quería preguntar en su opinión
que ha sido lo que más le ha afectado al
al uribismo digamos ad hoc el cual
cuando hacía los factores y hay varios
uno es que como viendo el proceso de paz
el proceso de paz trajo justicia
transicional y la justicia transicional
ha empezado a levantar las alfombras y
sobre de bajo las alfombras hay mucha
sangre en colombia entonces por ejemplo
6.402 'falsos positivos' o que son
ejecuciones extrajudiciales es una
mancha muy grande para cualquier líder
político porque ese disfraz masacre de
una población inerme que ocurrió en
medio de los gobiernos del uribismo y
entonces esta situación pues le ha
mandado un mensaje muy fuerte al propio
presidente uribe y a todo su grupo
político
luego también está que hay una propuesta
de seguridad
de parte del uribismo que ya pasó es ese
momento ya el péndulo colombiano no gira
entre paz y seguridad el péndulo
colombiano vuelve gira lo como gira
normalmente en europa y en otras partes
entre izquierda y derecha cuando el tema
social pasa a primer lugar la izquierda
tiene muchas posibilidades de triunfar
cuando el tema de seguridad es el
primero y el más importante la derecha
siempre tiene más posibilidades pero
aquí estamos en un cambio duro de la
realidad nacional y el uribismo sigue
con un discurso viejo transnochado el
mensaje que ellos mandan es oiga
colombiano la debemos convertir en
venezuela colombia no la debemos dominar
por el castrochavismo y esas son
expresiones que van pasando de moda
porque ya no es un fantasma ni el
castrochavismo
y que vamos a convertirlo en venezuela
porque realmente es muy distinta a
colombia a venezuela y nadie así se lo
propusiera podría convertir a colombia
en venezuela león también le quiero
preguntar si digamos sube la izquierda
en estas elecciones presidenciales que
ya están a la vuelta de la esquina aquí
en colombia podemos ver pues
evidentemente un cambio político como
usted lo dijo en más de 60 años en el
país pero más allá de eso que tendría
que hacer la derecha en este caso el
uribismo representado para volver a
tomar las riendas de un país en unas
próximas elecciones o que no será tan
pisoteada digamos luego de estas
elecciones cuando suba a la izquierda si
es que sube es que realmente pues se
normaliza la democracia raúl si sube la
izquierda se normaliza la democracia
esta ha sido una democracia que no ha
dejado gobernar nunca la izquierda
mediante la violencia y la exclusión
entonces llega a un gobierno de
izquierdas se normaliza la democracia y
las fuerzas derecha hacia una oposición
se tiran a la oposición ojalá respeten
el resultado electoral y en la oposición
todos los medios para ser oposición
empecemos por esto en la revista semana
para decir algo que ahora juega como
aliada del gobierno y el uribismo de
manera digamos al mal vergonzosa
periodismo
vergonzoso va a seguramente hacer la
oposición dura digamos a desde los
medios de comunicación
al nuevo gobierno de izquierdas y
seguramente toda la prensa tenga un ojo
muy crítico frente a ese gobierno de
izquierdas y ese gobierno de izquierdas
tendrá que demostrar digamos que es
capaz de dirigir un país complejo como
colombia un país con una exclusión muy
grande a la población con 20 millones de
personas en la pobreza con la
concentración de la tierra más alta del
mundo con unos niveles de violencia y
disputa de rentas enormes con un poco de
grupos y asediando lo con una posición
muy aislada en américa latina por la
actitud digamos frente a los países
vecinos del gobierno actual y el
uribismo entonces tendrá un gobierno
complejo en los salones
y en todos los mentideros políticos será
muy dura la posición frente a ellos el
empresariado mismo se le impondrá muchas
condiciones a un gobierno de las
izquierdas las fuerzas militares también
tendrá una gobernabilidad compleja una
gobernabilidad
que rompe digamos con 200 años de
dominio de unas o las élites políticas y
entonces eso pues no será fácil para
iniciarse pero los weeks de izquierdas
dicen oiga no vamos a tener muchos
problemas y llegamos a gobernar yo pero
es mejor tener los problemas de gobernar
y no los de ser oposición siempre como
hemos ido por antecedentes 60 años y yo
les digo oiga
para tena oran tienen que mostrar
digamos que si realmente tiene una
posición ética distinta que si tienen
una posición distinta frente a la
conducción del país y que si son capaces
de gobernar este país complejo y en
cierta lo en el mundo y en el siglo 21
ahora también no hay que dejar también
atrás a los seguidores que son varios
del presidente álvaro uribe no que son
ya una generación entre 50 a 60 años de
edad en contraste con esta generación
nueva digamos de estos jóvenes que están
ya volcados a las izquierdas a un cambio
político en el país porque estos dos
contrastes y también de generación que
digamos hizo en su momento el presidente
álvaro uribe para que estas personas
todavía lo sigan
en su movimiento político es que él
realmente fue un impacto muy grande en
la vida colombiana presidente uribe en
un momento de la vida recogió el sentir
de la sociedad colombiana sobre la
seguridad sobre la serie de las
guerrillas sobre que este país tenía
digamos unos niveles muy altos de
violencia
ofreció una por digamos una una
propuesta de seguridad dura y con esa
propuesta seguridad se fue a gobernar lo
favorecían las encuestas enormemente lo
favoreció el giro mundial la ataque las
torres gemelas de nueva york eso era en
el momento en que él estaba en campaña
eso lo catapultó porque la cosa es la
lucha antiterrorista a nivel mundial
cogió mucha fuerza y el segundo en esa
ola y en esa ola
se envanece o con el poder y creyó que
podía hacer todo en nombre de la
seguridad entonces hizo tantas cosas
indebidas a nombre de la seguridad que
bueno eso le está cobrando y está
pasando cuenta de cobro la historia pero
el fanatismo político es parte digamos
de la vida de cualquier país y aquí hay
un grupo fanático muy ligado a él un
grupo duro que fue muy favorecido por su
gobierno por ejemplo empresarios del
campo como los bananeros y los ganaderos
los palmeros los azucareros que son una
digamos un empresariado importante fue
muy favorecido y astoria base de su de
su gobierno aquí en colombia los pueblos
pequeños todavía hay mucho uribismo
en los estratos digamos en los estratos
altos y hay mucho uribismo en las
personas de mayores de 50 años
hay menos uribismo en el mundo urbano
y en el mundo hobby
eso es lo que hay y es toda la digamos
genere digamos un hablar un nuevo
pluralismo en colombia ahora hay
fenómenos importantes no sólo políticos
sino sociales es que tener a francia
márquez en una candidatura a la
vicepresidencia con posibilidades yo me
imagino el impacto que tendrá una negra
que estaba en un estrato
1 de la población
y que llega a representar lo que dicen
los nadies y ya ha sido un impacto
enorme en la vida colombiana y
seguramente empoderar a a muchos negros
a muchos indígenas a muchos pobres a
muchas mujeres a gente que busca un
camino para participar en la política
colombiana y la vida social de colombia